hi I'm Joshua Lou Freedman I mean the
first ad on the set all right guys
wardrobe is clear make them familiar
move table for sir
quiet freeze lock it up all right all
right
pictures up do you say okay tell me
where I can go yeah
pictures up lock it up
what's roll sound roll camera
Seanie 71 take 3 mark great and coming
with your sec ok it was an 8 o'clock
call I got here around 7:30 sometimes if
it's in you location I'll get there an
hour earlier but its location I'd
already been living in I'll be here at
like 7:30 as an example it was a typical
hours spent on set 12-hour days I'm not
counting lunch but then you know with
the before the travel time I before I
live like an hour away so that's kind of
sucks typically it's a 12-hour day but
then with lunch at 13 hour day sometimes
fortune our day so it depends if we go
over when we get here I try to get all
the actors you know at first they do a
blocking rehearsal for the director of
photography and our director and all the
department heads to see so we know what
we're lighting and what we're shooting
and we work out as many bugs as we can
and I put the actors through the works
makeup and hair wardrobe while we're
lighting the set and then when they come
when they're ready the set is hopefully
ready by then and we do a camera
rehearsal and then we shoot and we knock
out all the scenes on the day as
scheduled in prep it's the most useful
job on set as it is because all the
department heads are kind of bottleneck
in pyramid so on and when we go over
then I have to make or what bit
something's taking too long I have to
get the director to hopefully make
concessions on how many shots he
actually you know it was my job to adapt
to the director to make sure that he
gets what he wants sometimes I'll make
sure he gets what he needs rather than
what he wants instead depends on if we
are running behind or not and usually I
can make that work we're going to the
flip
fair line when they're walking
away where he's like move your ass and
pushes him into the room for that wait
up that cable will go from them to these
guys okay
during that whole exchange then we're
going to get a shot of them here well is
walk you through I'm going to get an
insert shot that has to match for a
transition of Kevin's arm going onto
this door and then after that I'm just
gonna let it be fuzzy fad special parts
hammer out okay where you one of those
that drives on the strings yeah I I get
that yes that that is true
um it's starting to take its toll I'm
not gonna lie to you I'm an old man but
old old man
I have Zack Ward on set immediately
please I'm always the guy like every
time I have jobs book they never seem to
be a couple days after I rap or a week
after I rap it's always oh you're done
shooting on the 16th perfect you're
starting with us on the 17th and that's
been the story of my life for years
um so very rarely do I get time off time
off is one of those things that happen
to other people well sounds like oh you
love to be on set I do I do I did I do
to thrive on the stress that's I
admittedly and but yeah takes its toll
on very mellow when I'm not on set but
definitely you got to keep things moving
you know my pace dictates you know the
crew the departments and how fast the
crew works so you got to keep that
energy going wait walk it up ages up
have any ones on the face 71 straight up
here we go everyone to one good swing
boy
quiet everywhere you're just joining us
now it's a lovely time and say your cell
phones on stun light go ahead sorry but
my um department has want to know for
doing a free life or any of the scenes
no it's a hospital room in here
samples are pretty good yeah well this
will be changed because this is the old
look this is a vengeance work so we're
going into modern look
not even sure if it's still this room it
might be the room across the way cool
boy here James tub double check but let
me see which one he wants to use thank
you very much no worries Oh indoors and
shooting outdoors obviously indoors is
more controllable especially during
sound stages and you control so much
more outside you're at the mercy of the
elements the weather you have to power
the lights if you're using lights noise
factors also play into it
airplanes and helicopters which we tend
to get a lot of here now a lot of here
in LA and yeah so it's easier to shoot
indoors I want you to doing this come on
since 1991 not to say dangers in the
industry since 91 so a long time very
long time have you seen it changed
especially now with DSLR oh yeah
dramatically actually on I I just saw
the change when I did the third film I
were to shoot on a red and it was like
ah this magic can still change things in
LA at first there's a lot of directors
that were alike all pro always shoot on
film and now most have come around to
say I'll never again so some some will
hold on to the purist will hold on to
that but you know it's the way of the
future you know and yes everything's
changed dramatically some things are
easier and some things are actually more
difficult in the back end like you know
the advent of HD a tree like I feel bad
for makeup artists because in HD it
really separates the pros from the
amateurs because you see you catch so
much more definition in detail I say I
felt at most around 2007 2008 where
really was just everyone was going
digital
all right boys and girls ladies and
gentlemen pictures up last looks last
looks during prep I'm responsible for
putting the schedule together um it's
it's very it's a time-honored art to
prep the film and to schedule it
accordingly and so that's basically your
baby in a way is a schedule you know you
haven't written the script that's the
director of the mine whose baby are the
directors the way he shoots it that's
his baby and the writer how he writes it
that's his baby I schedule it that's my
baby so it's kind of like seeing that
baby come to fruition is making a
schedule that works that that we're
making as we stay on schedule and I that
part I do thrive thrive on movie magic
is what I use it's kind of an industry
standard so there's a shooting schedule
that I put together there's all your
cast members and this is it I have to
you know group all the locations within
a day and see what works with location
stipulations actress stipulations or all
the different scenes and here's every
day of the shoot and all this has to be
ironed out during the prep and I put all
this together and then on top of that
each one of these scenes needs to be
broken down don't they
for all the elements so I have what's
also called the breakdown and I do these
every scene as you can see you know as
I'm broken out or who's in it what props
are needed what vehicles are needed
makeup notes stunts wardrobe is notes
yeah so every scene has to be broken
down like that and then of course though
you've seen the schedule and put in an
order that makes sense for the
production and I always turn in a
breakdown in both schedule order and see
an order so it's easier for the
department heads to kind of bounce
around and see what they need by
lunchtime we have the drop what's called
a preliminary and I make sure the
department has take a look at it so they
can throw in there a few cents and I go
over it with the director and my second
idea over lunch you actually you know
why who puts it together I approve it
and make the changes and we like to have
enough by the end of the day if you know
because things change like what the
scene has to push from today to tomorrow
in fact
case then you know and it needs to be on
a call she's attended out or emailed at
the end of the night so usually end of
the day if nothing's changed
dramatically since the lunchtime meeting
that will hand out a call to the end of
the day they definitely get it an email
form as well so yeah end of the day I
love when I'm done with prep because I'm
more of a I mean I got the paperwork
down to a science but at the same time I
prefer to be on set I'm not a paperwork
I I gotta keep the keep the earth moving
let's go again going again right away oh
yeah right away reset please everyone to
one ya know looks last looks playing I
love it when things are cut out I like
I'll really and I get that all the time
or directors like I still like the scene
we're gonna have to cut this inner that
so you know like I'm so sorry to hear
that it's great except means I have more
time to get other things and make my day
listen up a great job by the way coming
in on Eastern working hand and knocking
out our day this earlier we were
thinking about stealing a scene we're
not going to so we are going to wrap
early under the auspices that everyone
understands in our last day day after
tomorrow we will most likely go over
okay it's about in low down low it in
load out and a company move and that's
also the day that this scene that we
were going to pick up is is on so we
were going to pick it up to make it
lighter but we figured you guys would
rather have Easter and the couple hours
early done now now that being said on
that last day we will have a proper
second meal available for everybody when
that time comes okay so yeah we we have
we have a question because if it is not
okay with anybody that we are doing that
we can still we still have time to pick
that up today I need to make sure
everybody is actually okay with this and
if they are not we will push for it
today today yeah but if everybody's okay
with it you all can go home right now
and feel free to step forward I mean
don't know it's it's either way we're
going to get the scene so it's not it's
data you do not have to feel bad if you
I have a problem with it yes certain
certain seems like to turn into what I
call time vampires and I'm a huge fan of
you knows that's when I start to get a
little meaner on set I was at AG you
have to walk a fine line between you
know being stern and yet keeping a
jovial attitude you know keeping morale
high and I do walk that fine line but if
a scene is taking too long
that changes or I have to really start
cracking the whip and puttin my foot
down so yeah so it's almost like you're
playing good cop and bad cop Lindsay at
the same time yeah it's very
schizophrenic no it's not yes it is
anyway so you know who said that
Haymarket yeah come on dad hold on quiet
and Hatchin yeah it doesn't happen often
but there are curveballs that you never
see coming
you can't prep for you can't plan for
and it's it's the experience of an ad an
experience staging to be able to rise to
those challenges that come that the ones
you don't see coming and to be a problem
solver and find ways to fix it based on
my experience so yeah those are the ones
and you never know you know you never
see them coming you can't predict them
without naming names or titles it was an
airplane set and it was day one our
first day of shooting and we were going
to shoot in a cockpit and our department
promised this cockpit they were building
was going to be great and they sent
pictures of the plans to the director
and promised it would look good and
they'd work and things weren't I heard
like we're two days of shooting and the
build wasn't they weren't sending
pictures and whatnot so we weren't going
to see anything till that day they're
going to build all night it was going to
look beautiful and you know the
producers were like we're taking a
chance on that we showed up that morning
everything was barely built and we were
waited and we waited and we waited and
when they finally built this company I
wake you out we've called lunch and we
haven't shot anything yet and then after
lunch by the time they finish the
cockpit the director looked at it and
said we're not shooting this one looks
like crap
so I'm like what do we we had to rent a
cockpit from a rental house had it
trucked had it on
brought it over to the soundstage it was
big pain yes getting that cockpit
rebuilt cockpit off the truck and into
the soundstage and we had to address it
and rig it and light it and I finally
got my shot right before I called wrap
that was an 80s nightmare that all to
have this whole day scheduled so
thankfully on day two I did evolved I
made sure I brought in day one and day
two at the same time and put us back on
schedule
the same day so that was that was
probably one of the most challenging
things had never never my career have I
not gotten a shot before lunch let alone
at the end of the day it's just
preposterous and to have a whole set
thrown out and another one brought in it
was just mind-boggling
so yeah crazy Tuesdays everybody bring
rain gear rain gear for your dugout for
your equipment and what-have-you
all right guys great getting work today
seriously guys stick a fork in it that's
a wrap
Happy Easter oh very nice that's around